are you gonna wear those sunglasses the
whole time you know what I don't even
realize when they're on or off anymore
what does that mean cuz you know why
because my my life is that cool okay so
when I have sunglasses on indoors I
don't realize that okay so I want to ask
you something
yo don't do that go ahead shoot ponder
you you are welcome to welcome two
fighter in the kid yes I know Chris
D'Elia is guesting yeah well is it well
looks like Miss su mo first of all your
shoes make you
those are lifts obviously they're not
only outside of dude I'm six-two well
they're not they're air maxes dude
you're acting like they're [ __ ] well
and they're gold right there Gold yeah
well they're matte they're like you know
the in a stock's don't go I don't care
cuz I'm not in the fashion that's
obvious slam you start out with a
[ __ ] grand slam not a slam hey man we
got a bunch of [ __ ] specials here at
Denny's but you just wanted the good old
fashioned Grand Slam that's not John
that wasn't a slam and your mouth is
twisted in such a disrespectful manner
be respectful okay I'm respectful dude I
know what I actually am respectful and
I'll tell you why and I'm gonna take off
my sunglasses because I'm gonna be
respectful here and I'm not a piece of
[ __ ] and well there's an on piece of
[ __ ] do comes comes bearing gifts
I got you from a gift from Starbucks not
I can't I know you like this stuff no I
can't eat that you know why Harry and I
have psoriasis because it's sweet senses
were simply strawberry eat that from
Starbucks and I got it for you and now I
drink a black [ __ ] iced americano now
that's as hard as it gets dude and I got
that for you because you're a sweet tart
tart Nash that's why man I got you that
pink [ __ ] simply strawberry it cost
about 450 and that didn't make a [ __ ]
but I got it for you because you're a
sweet heart depart Nass do it you
[ __ ] I can't I don't drink it all no
I won't number one I have psoriasis and
that will aggravate my skin number two
number two I don't wouldn't eat this
anyway because I'm a hard dude myself
you're not a hard dude you look cute as
shown at that
don't take it yeah oh that's it you have
a pink iPhone case I do because I wanted
to match because I knew I was coming to
see you I change it with every day I got
a pink iPhone case for this because I
knew I was matches you're pausing no no
no because I knew I was coming here and
I want it to match your sweet heart
tartness do it don't say it like that I
don't want this this is a divider in the
kid anymore this is the the [ __ ] the
the real the Super Deluxe oh kid no and
the [ __ ] sweet tart tart nasty no no
hey welcome to the Super Deluxe Oh kid
and the sweet tart turn - you're not the
name you're not gonna rebrand this show
that I've work sold out of the building
all right the [ __ ] is where's the other
guy who cares where the other guy is
that's right we're taking a break from
the other guy now let me ask you this
you are we all know that you are you
only live in Chris Ville okay and that's
okay cuz I won't do it then only see as
far as Chris Ville
now is there anything in the news that
is effective setting you you feel like
you need to contribute - yeah of course
do me give me it what is I'm [ __ ] I
I'm firing at all on all cylinders -
what is it and I know all about the news
and what's going on okay well I don't
you know I don't like what's going on in
the world [ __ ] generally specifically
okay can you get okay so what
specifically do you not like going on I
don't mean to put you on the spot but I
just like my work because I feel like
you are a little bit no I'm trying to
I'm trying to expand your horizons and I
feel like right now you're only reaching
as far as Chris Phil and I want to know
if there's any way it's not like that
that we can look beyond that so what
about the news is bothering well there
it's a very politically charged
atmosphere and that's and in general man
no but we have to figure out what the
[ __ ] to do
on all fronts because if we don't then I
don't know whether this I honestly don't
know where this country's headed
I see Europe I see history repeating
itself ah I see saying a lot of stuff
III see if we're not careful I see I see
us getting into a lot of hot water and
worryin hot water what we gotta do is we
gotta get out of that hot hot water get
her head above water okay man you're
sounding a lot like Trump when he was he
was wrong for office you're being wrong
that's what he did what he goes wrong he
let me finish okay well you were wrong
though well I didn't mean to do what he
did but you were not specific at all we
all know that you were wrong all of us
no never wrong
no man you're pulling everything every
way saying that you're wrong
nobody's saying you don't know everyone
said you're bullying your way out of
this conversation so you with the tiny
ankles where honey ankles well you have
we're I think what happened in the wound
oh it's all right dude but that area
didn't grow right no I don't say it
doesn't who cares we're gonna move on
from this it's fitting your big feet now
from your ankles to your hip yeah it
seems to me what okay none that don't
say okay don't care but why do seems to
me that after the age of 14 that area
took a break okay come back okay but
everything else grew no that's not sir
so who cares that you have 14 year old
legs but you would agree with that don't
say that I work out my legs all the time
I do it all the time is very hard but
I'm you know what I mean I'm trying and
there's only up from here which is why
sports not for you cuz sport comes from
the legs at the end of the day right
yeah I know that but sports
dude yeah game Oh so sports are for you
dude sports are for you what I'm an
apple all right you don't say that man
you're not a [ __ ] arrow but I'm
victimizing it for heaven I'm an [ __ ]
really I've never taken a break from my
sport this my sports all right no it's a
little stress is give me chess now you
technically when you take me in
well you take me in row I don't take you
in then visually would you take me and
periodically no and you and you and and
I've seen this happen and I don't I
don't blame you but there's a there's a
primordial thing that happens when a
real alpha walks in the room and you do
this and I've seen you do it I don't
care
you go you just hold on you right well
no I don't usually what I'm standing in
my space not fulfilling the impression
that God has given me in the world I do
what and I feel it well you go dude I
don't breathe like that when I [ __ ]
first of all I don't take you in well
it's involuntary but when because what I
do is I it's not involuntary that
doesn't happen I've heard you do this
you're telling saying when you walk in
yeah and you go what you're seeing is is
the hard true and very full well truth
right no no no that is you're saying
when when you walk in I go like this
yeah and you say this no that's stupid
he's the answers but I've heard a [ __ ]
out of here right maybe it's it maybe I
misheard get out of here dude I'm sorry
I'm nasally guys you guys I'm really
nasally wise I got stuffed up because
dude I'm [ __ ] nasally by I went to
the doctor the other day and I go like
this what is it and he's like dude
sometimes you're just [ __ ] too sick
with it that's not what the doctors I
was like I'm sorry and he was like yeah
he looked at me up from his glasses and
goes like this there's really nothing I
could prescribe you I said but you're
the doctor he said I know but there's
nothing we can do
you're just too sick with it he said
you're too sick with it and I'm like
that's why I'm nasally and he says
that's my best guess too sick with it so
WI DD T yeah or D I don't know I don't
even know but he just goes you're sick
with it man you are sick with it and
then I go out and I go to pay and I was
like what do I owe and they were like
you know what we don't want to charge
you we love your work but you're come on
I know I know I said I'll tell come on
please right I know I was in your shoes
right here I was like please let me pay
something you know at least two three
grand I don't know how much it cost you
know but they were like whatever doesn't
make a and but and then but she was like
she was like yeah you're sick with it
and I was like ah it's all good she's
like I knew somebody who was sick with
it once I was like who and she said a
Gregory Peck I was like Jesus that was a
long time ago
but apparently you know he was very
famous it was like more your time period
but um that's there's it like The Grapes
of Wrath which was big right around when
Brian was forty all right but but
congratulatory is very funny Sam
congratulatory because my podcast
congratulations is just skyrocketing in
the charts man you've been talking about
yourself the whole time no need to start
talking about other things besides
yourself not people you know what's
funny I'm not talking about myself but I
think I I swear to God there was a
second a few months ago I started
thinking of I started thinking that my
name was what the [ __ ] it's him you're
insufferable no no this is other people
I know what's going on dude I've been
around you yeah you get recognized okay
but don't act like you're not Justin
people no no that's what I say to them
I'm like guys no it's not Justin Bieber
and they go like what the [ __ ] it's I
thought my name for it for a second I
sort of got it now my name was what the
[ __ ] there he is no no and I was like
what my name is Chris yeah and they're
like yeah we know yeah and you know I've
seen a lot of pictures of you sometimes
that on the internet when you're young
mmm when you didn't have a beard and
when you had short hair mm-hmm and it
was interesting because like that's the
guy with the lunch pail right
what well wait what well some people go
through a transition and what they do is
they go there's the guy you shove in the
corner okay I'm your lunch whatever it
is right or or let's just shove him
around or or you know what that's what
they do right ya know and then then go
then you get mad in the mirror and you
I'm gonna change that's true and then
you go any of your dad's like let's get
them a stylist yeah I don't care how
much it cost I don't know dude I don't
and then and then you do you're glad to
pay the stylist two thousand ten
thousand whatever and then he got the
Chagos crow your hair long gross scruff
and then reinvent yourself because you
your name used to be Dennis
now it's Chris is that true no that's
not true my name who's never Dennis it
could have been back then right all
right no it was not it couldn't have
been my name is Chris and only Chris
wait a minute death it would have made a
death and also people [ __ ] if
anything my name is what the [ __ ] it's
him and that's what I'm saying now when
you're at your holiday what you post
videos sometimes if you're you and
you're your home your dad can barely
barely take you and your brother like I
said the most ridiculous comments true
we do we have ridiculous conversations
but you know what he made us so it's his
fault I know it's not you guys are close
though yeah we were very close his mom
good how's dad good how's your brother
who looks up to me
no that's not actually he's skinny I
could beat his head okay dude okay but
why are you saying when I see him I go
about punch you in the chest once you'd
quit but why would you say that to him
but why would you say that I just want
him to know that I can kick his ass
all right dude yeah I like I can kick
his ass and by the way if he's walking
around with his girl
I'll take her if I want bro okay you
don't need to say that I wouldn't know
well I've all right I go to when I go
hey scram all right that's some 1960s
[ __ ] and I know what you say scram -
my brother one time no no that's
disrespectful [ __ ] Korando and then and
then you you go nah bro yeah you know
Brian don't you tell you you try to
peacock up and die bro I go what know
what I'm too lazy for you to deal with
bro I'm too like you for you to deal
with you want you want a spat huh
you want to dad brought me that's
absolutely not how it will go down you
want these [ __ ] spaghetti arms
wrapped around your [ __ ] neck dude
you in the mood for some dye in huh you
in the mood for some [ __ ] dalian food
now you say when you [ __ ] up I got like
that I look at people dead [ __ ]
square in the eye and I say hey dude are
you hungry
cuz I got some dyin food for you for
years and then I [ __ ] whip around
there
no they're like weird ego and I'm behind
them just strangling the [ __ ] out of
really strangle I don't even choke I
stretch okay take it easy the last time
you thought you were in a fight oh god
dude so many times we have you and your
brother ever come to fisticuffs only one
time really yeah how old were you
young college to him you did yeah cuz he
was choking me
or he punched me or something I don't
remember younger brother - yeah and you
you beat him up he was punching me or
something then I let him have it but I
was bigger and older so now dude don't
be it was probably about some cool [ __ ]
like money or checks yeah are you
drinking your [ __ ] because I'm not
Auburn I'm not a tart heart and ass you
are at you're a [ __ ] sweet tart tart
NASA no I'm not welcome to the Super
Deluxe okayed and the sweet tart not
NASA now what's going on with you oh
dude no hey dude Brian tries to take it
down to a boring ville [ __ ] what do
you want to talk about bro we're here
this is it yeah [ __ ] Brendan Schaub
he's not here huh no he's not guy
doesn't eat honestly doesn't eat you
know what he doesn't have he doesn't
have the [ __ ] determination that's
why he's not how I feel
yep and I'll tell you something else
he's often authors and he's working on
other business videos that's right he's
being mr. entrepreneur yeah I don't have
that in me I'm not a beautiful former
bro I'm a performer yep he's got all
kinds of ventures I know he's gonna be
like very wealthy yeah god bless him I
go like this I go oh cool that's good
thank you guys let's talk about big
brown coffee I'm like all right I'm
worse I'm surprised you showed up here
before I did to be honest no I've been
on time later yeah no if you had a sound
effect for who you are and what your
life is what would it be
don't be a dick okay won't be honest
okay Krista Leah's life give me a sound
effect don't be okay just be honest you
want to hear it is it no it's not that
I don't know you know what it is it's
this
Shh and that's obviously that's a rocket
taking off yep and then turning into
[ __ ] sparkly flames yep really yeah
and I'm right I'm stumped if you can
believe it or not I'm still at the
launching sequence really right now cuz
I've what's up I was trying them for me
I guess I guess you really oh right oh
right but yours will be oh no no I I I'm
not to be a dick I think mine because
I'm older and I've kind of gotten to
where it's like I I'm Oh in a way
because I've ever well no I've I've
broken through that so so you're still
trying to find it and in a way when you
reach that you go I've been here this
whole time you know that it comes full
circle yeah it does well I don't [ __ ]
believe a word you say but that's how
about that how often you YouTube my
stand up to inspire you do you have
clips on YouTube and besides this
[ __ ] show do you have time for do
you have clip yeah I stay up on yeah
soup
yeah I do you know the Kevin Hart after
I did ride-along called me up and he
goes hey man I'm just calling I'm
wondering why why do you only have like
like 170 view thousand he's talking
about is you don't know him I do huh I
know Kevin Hart dude we did the [ __ ]
Justin Bieber roast and I saw him a few
months ago at the Comedy Store and he
brought me up on stage well I have to
read bumped me nah but not for long hey
you're doing Carnegie Hall yeah I'm you
Little Joe yeah I mean he'd be a big
deal Carnegie Hall yeah I know actually
it's pretty crazy I do you realize how
Chris you know you book these dates and
like you're not sure about like you
don't think about it you just book a
bunch of dates and then like when I
promoted the Carnegie Hall one when I
put it on my Instagram I got so many
texts I was like well you're playing
Carnegie Hall and I was like [ __ ] I
guess that is cool don't you think about
it though when it's you you know yeah
but Carnegie Hall's are almost like all
[ __ ] aside it's almost like the
pinnacle I mean you can play Stadium
yeah sure I don't think I think Carnegie
Hall is like literally literally that
there's a joke or there's a saying how
do you get to Carnegie Hall Pratt right
right right right yeah true I think you
look at that look at that are you gonna
fill that yeah that's where the the
biggest performance in the world that is
[ __ ] beautiful
look at that oh that's that's you don't
worry about history but that was built
not last year you know that that was
built a while ago yeah 2007 or so no no
no find out when Carnegie Hall was built
it's an unbelievable iterally like I I
think a huge mile I would say that's
probably the most famous theater right
100% yeah I think so yeah I mean that's
you don't get bigger than that what do
you do you find yourself for like saying
I think I'm just gonna um I'd like a do
you ever feel like 1941 43 43 Jared feel
like you just want to UM do stand-up
sometimes and not do anything else I
mean look it's like well how many
specials have you done to mine this is
my third okay so and did you do it yet
no I'm doing Oh in Chicago right 2020
yeah oh [ __ ] I want to go actually yeah
you shared a light xx yeah wonder if I
can it's just the thing that you're in
control of like I mean it you know I
guess you want to keep like growing or
whatever that means and talking about
other things in your life and you know
you live life and then document it by
doing a special right that's exactly
right but this I got diary yeah I
suppose but like so but it's also the
only thing you're in control of like in
Hollywood like you get gigs and and you
and you and you do them but as an actor
you have no control over it none unless
you're creating your own show but then
even still it's such a collaborative
thing yeah yeah it's a collaborative
thing which which is fun in its own way
yeah but it's it's not the would you
you're gonna find that your expression
is watered-down right one way or even
even even besides the fact that it's a
collaborative effort you then you get
the network involved yeah and they have
their own thing that they want to do and
they give you notes and it's just it's I
like doing that as well but for a
different reason but stand-up just seems
like the thing that you're always in
control or secure to it yeah you can do
it whenever you you know I mean I'm
doing this tour now and it's like it's
my livelihood and I don't have to say
yes to shows I don't want it and also I
feel like it's the last
place where you can actually still speak
your mind yeah
and that's amazing and even that's
[ __ ] tough now but yeah I mean I
still do it and and we need you get an a
backlash nah I don't mean I mean online
sometimes I go you shouldn't have talked
about this you shouldn't talk about that
but it's like I I don't care about that
you know it's like that I mean people
were getting that [ __ ] Chapelle on
his last special about saying things
that it's like if they're just so
they're so dumb
yeah it's the Liberals though you know
it's the Horde liberals that are just
say this you can't say that but I don't
you know I get why comedians don't want
to do colleges but I'll do them as long
as I tell you I did a corporate gig with
these lawyers and the woman came up oh
yes I'm sorry but this on the show yeah
a little bit but this woman came up she
was at this big time lawyer and she goes
you were really offensive and I had to
be up there for I had to give awards I
don't know why I did yeah I'm probably
not gonna do corporate gigs ever again
he's good money
it's crazy money but but I just don't
find them comfortable because I don't
know I think cuz I'm lying because I
think I feel like a liar I'm doing it
only for the dollar bill yeah and I'm in
some weird Auditorium and it's not built
for stand-up and they're all looking up
they're all that dare tables I'm not
liking I don't wanna do it yeah you
don't want to do it but who you kiddin
you say yes for a dollar but yeah well
that's the problem is they pay you a lot
I don't if I wanted to make money that
way I would work for a corporation yeah
and there's nothing wrong with that but
the woman goes you were the offense if I
go really what parts use the whole thing
and their friend goes you have a long
way to go do you
yep and I went thank you very much on
stage in yeah the microphone skills
usually but I but again I was like there
were lawyers they were all partners and
it was weird environment and they that
you you just come in and start doing
stand-up and they were like this is
uncomfortable because he's not being
very politically correct or say you have
a long way to go yeah I was incredibly
actually I didn't believe it and and she
said this in front of everybody and he
said in front of her whole her whole
like her I think was seven of them came
up do you know what what a hero she is
well that's it you know what I mean and
I said after after after an hour I came
back up on stage and I said I kind
addressed what she had said and then in
front of everybody and I kind of like
said if you if you think that I'm you
know essentially don't know why that's
offensive yeah and I was just doing I
was setting you up what did Joe Wright
write as an offensive anyway I go of
course I mean yeah actually you actually
came back around yeah because I was like
do you do like what are you doing and
also it was just was part of this
professionally offended you should have
just said thank you for your money yeah
I did yeah I did I said thank you I said
I got scolded and I pointed over there
it bothered me it really did it made me
angry and I don't get angry it made me
angry no parents actually but you know
what it is though it's like it's not
even the fact that it offends you it
because it's not that it's the audacity
somebody has to just say that I know
it's like it's not it's not like because
you know you're funny dude and you know
that person is just a boring piece of
[ __ ] to be honest although although
there is this like when I got up on
stage in Canada for just four laps and
Vern Cox who's a transgender actress on
orange is the new black when she was
hosting it so the crowd was pretty
little cannon a very liberal when I got
up on stage at first it was interesting
because there was I felt it was a very
very politically correct crowd anyway I
got him I got and I did well right but a
lot of people came up to me after me
that was so amazing we thought you were
gonna be this frat boy and then you told
us but that's what happens so they have
an image of you because you got a
forward tilt you're a dude and they're
expecting you to talk about chicks and
yeah but I'm not and it was it wasn't I
feeling - dude yeah you do rooms that
are like the off rooms or like the
[ __ ] you know all comedy round yeah
you do those and it's like first of all
there are in and dude completely like
there are some hilarious all calm yeah
like absolutely hilarious
um but sometimes I go in those rooms man
and and I swear to God
most of them most of the people there
are laughing because they're like you
yeah well it's your drowning and irony
irony it's so not funny that it's funny
it's like when you watch have you ever
gone to an me and up Davidoff went to a
[ __ ] modern art these modern art
galleries in Chelsea in New York oh my
god yeah they had a they had a sign it
said jungle jungle jungle it was a neon
sign it was $350,000 yeah I know
then there's string hanging from a
ceiling just string that would cost you
$100,000 yeah it's made by a certain
[ __ ] I know certain it's weird [ __ ]
calls himself an artist it's weird
there's a boulder in the middle of it
yeah a boulder is $300,000 yeah the
colored rock [ __ ] you use Allah the raw
bok Gil the rock on the car dented and
yeah that even that takes effort but
ever yeah no I know their [ __ ] that
there's no pull up pull up Modern Art
infuriates ridiculous I mean dude some
of it is so annoying infuriating yeah I
some of it taught me some of it's great
yeah like like like this [ __ ] is now
that's gonna paint it van Gogh right
there that is but no yeah I do not
really know bring up a stupid modern
artist it's so annoying
stupid but expensive modern art yeah
there you go
that doesn't go to that go the first one
those are that's just a white canvas oh
cool it's terrible that's a white canvas
and it's like they're like oh but we're
saying you know no you you're part of a
club yeah but it's like art isn't it's
like dude don't make a statement down
here don't try that hard to make a guy
stay you're part of a group that that
that costs hundreds of thousands of them
yep yep yep for about forty three
million dollars for that blue [ __ ]
forty three million dollars imagine
because the guy died there's a line
through it but he was the first to do it
oh that's two separate pieces dude we
went to an art of modeling and this
woman was looking at and I go it was it
was - it was logs and then it was um
this this weird like a plastic thing on
the ground I go what is it well whoever
thought of takin the sculptor and off
the the the amount and showcasing the
mount I was like doesn't David go Dolph
goes well I could tell a joke that falls
flat over and over again and just cuz I
put it in a large room with a skylight
doesn't mean it's good look at that
mm that that this is a messy bedroom
that's $50,000 150,000 Wow I'd beat the
[ __ ] out of how about I beat the [ __ ]
out of the guy who made that and anybody
who buys it and then we put them on the
bed yeah we soaked the bed with their
blood
oh there's that guy who does those
[ __ ] balloon animal thing right there
what's that guy's name he's like he be
he's like the guy who ever did that I
think at least that's kind of like well
yeah that would get it takes to take
something yeah I mean to make that but
but still this got no but the [ __ ] that
it's like millions and millions and
millions of dollars is when you have
that but does he he's he's smart
cuz he's a con man yeah he's people who
buy it are morons so these people are
they demonstrating against it
no those probably are fans but I forget
what the guy's name was he was really
big in the [ __ ] a few years ago and I
don't know if he's still super big but I
mean the guys sell [ __ ] for like forty
million dollars Oh crazy yeah Oh David
chose good though he's a different kind
of guy he did the art for he's a guy who
did the art for a Facebook before it was
Facebook and God shares in the company
the art for Facebook yeah I know he did
their mural on there like building or
they all yeah in the Ottawa offered on
30,000 for it or do you want stock no
and he took stock yeah he takes good
Johnny Joe if you had I think if I had
that much money though I don't know well
I definitely do stand up still but I
think I'd be a I'd have you killed the
what I would well I have you banned oh
and then I'd read Jeff Koons that's what
it is Jeff Koons yeah Koons
oh that well Koons is famous oh shut up
you didn't know no you know no it's
David Koons it chef David Kuhn no Jeff
Koons is a famous pop artist he's called
a pop artist um but that's just so weird
huh how weird is art it's like I get the
abstract
mists of it and like how it can be
beautiful but it's like once you start
veering away from an art shouldn't just
be what's realistic right but like
obviously it's easy to tell something is
super good if it's painted super
realistically because like oh okay wow
you imitated how yeah their life is but
then when you start getting
into the like you know well Jackson
Pollock around is Jackson Pollock is
it's like okay
and there's rhythms and [ __ ] and yeah
you know our - it's not and is your dad
and brother and tart no no not not
painting and [ __ ] not sculpture it's all
different things that guy Jackson bog
was was a legit there's a there's a
method to that madness I don't know what
it is but there's I don't know what it
is either but I mean or maybe not you
know but see there's you know it's
something you know it's like yeah
there's stuff in there and then his wife
started doing started painting she's
good too is sheis wife's very good yeah
guy doesn't [ __ ] know you know dick
do you have any art on your walls
no I paint I'm a painter what do you
paint
I'm careful honestly bring up one
painting right now in italic pieces
YouTube yep Cox oh god we have my pink
Cox I love painting kar-wai really
little little Cox Allah God has nothing
to do not big ones at all you don't
paint actual Cox you don't paint on no
no I would never paint it have you ever
had it a [ __ ] another person's [ __ ] in
your hand no do never in your light no
nevermind ever had a [ __ ] a hard [ __ ] in
there no have you oh god yeah that's
okay what color was it
it was dark as night but I remember my
friend in college said I don't know you
ever see a [ __ ] like a hard [ __ ] and you
just want to grab it no it swear to God
and I was like you're gay yeah and no I
haven't what did he say and then my
acting teacher one time I was like you
guys you straight guys even you straight
guys you don't cause when you suck each
other although you know and I go and
nobody sitting I go I don't do that I
never did I never had an urge to do that
he goes and he goes yeah sure right and
he kind of down with a conversation I
look at my really I [ __ ] do you do
that my buddies I got a buddy the
comedian
gay comedian Thomas Dale you know Thomas
no he's always like yeah everybody
everybody you can get anybody you can
get any straight guy to [ __ ] no there
suck no no yeah I'm like I don't think
so man said they're not ideas like
unless you look like a gal yeah oh yeah
he's a good guy oh he's so the guys
funny man he is right yes yeah he's so
funny yeah look yeah he's very funny
Thomas Dale love that guy um yeah no I
mean he's a good-looking guy yeah Tom
Cruise when I met him I've met a lot of
stars stars okay man I was talking to
him for an hour and a half and I wanted
to be his friend because I was so
starstruck [ __ ] because I had done a
reading with him before that and he was
like you're the best and I'm a row he's
really nice to me and I remember
thinking to myself he'd like if I was if
he wanted to make out with me it would
be I'm so starstruck that I'd have to
like I'd be like oh I have a stomachache
and I have to run away yeah yeah I
wouldn't be able if I was one percent
more gay I would do it yeah yeah yeah
that's how badly I want to be yeah but
that's not being gay that's just you
being like a [ __ ] starstruck
God I start [ __ ] start your you're a
you're a star everybody's a star [ __ ]
right depending on the star who have you
met I suppose so yeah what what famous
person have you meant that I holy [ __ ]
um the guys that I have met that where I
was like wow or Keanu Reeves you know I
like Arif uh and uh probably Vince
Vaughn oh yeah I [ __ ] I'm a huge of
it I think he's a crazy so funny yeah I
like him go ahead oh well when I was a
kid Jim Carrey yeah I was I was 14 you
met him yeah I remember I didn't wash my
hands for a few days
no how funny is that no yep and then
when I went and she's cool I went to
Montreal last year and and Jim was on my
flight for the I'm dying up here thing
that he was promoting and I've I didn't
know and then I hear hey Chris and I
look up now Kerry yeah no and I was like
oh hey what's up like I mean apparently
he knew I was because I'm a comedian I
guess but like I was like oh hey man
how's it going he's like how are you and
I was like good and he was like no
really though how are you know well let
you know by the end of the flight I
guess and he was like haha well good
seeing ya and I was like okay cool and I
was like Jesus Christ I just have a
[ __ ] conversation with Jim Carrey and
he knows who I am do you know that mean
that's amazing and and then and then we
landed here
yeah yet
no I think he had just shaved it was
like right and then and that yeah he did
just get just shaved because we brought
in the show and then we got off the
plane and we got off the plane we were
walking through customs and [ __ ] talking
to each other we're talking about Trump
actually he um he does art now yeah he's
um he's I think he's a bit manic or he's
bipolar or he he I think he just deals
with depression or maybe just got so
famous he was like ah whatever but talk
about so good but talk about like he's
so talented dude oh yeah I mean like his
art is I mean good it's really good yeah
man he's and and he's no joke man I know
is it's crazy housing joke he's a real
artist I guess lack of a better word
yeah
the only thing is that that sometimes
people like that get away from what they
are so good at sure and and and then
they feel like what they do because in a
way they've mastered it oh yeah yeah
well look at uh yeah which is why a lot
of guys don't do stand-up anymore like
Steve Steve Martin yeah I think
ultimately that might be a mistake it
would be for me only because only
because I would I would have to fill the
void I'd have to turn on stand-up in one
way or another like I I already have a
love/hate relationship with success and
everything so it would be bad for me
look at that that's good
is that him and he paint that or is that
just somebody painted him though
is someone painted oh yeah this is
artist Fabien correct you know he's okay
he's not a great artist but he's okay I
mean his stuff is but it's it's it's its
own style it's it's it's like you don't
see [ __ ] like it and it's good it takes
Talent I mean like I I don't think I
could do that yeah I don't know I don't
know I think it's good I think I think
he's one of those guys yeah that just
can figure out how to do the thing yeah
like Rogen is that way Joe Logan like
whatever hope he'll do it he obsesses
yeah he won't play golf cuz of that
I said stay away from golf cuz you'll go
crazy yeah yeah yeah yeah the way he is
with archery I'm sure he'll know for
sure in mine with witkoff those guys
feel like that are a special kind of
person I know I mean that they obsess me
I'm not like that I mean I obsessed but
about like
two or three things yeah me too no like
stand up I'm uncompromising right right
but but everything else and you wouldn't
know that watching your act but it's
it's it's crazy right that's an
underhanded ye are no not not great yeah
at what at practice stand up
oh no whoo great a price no my tennis
and boxing is no joke but yeah first of
all my hands are heavy and fast you know
that you know what it is though comes
from my legs absolutely you're not use
appeareance but by the way why my legs
are just as strong as yours no that's
not true in my legs if you look at like
my ass and the way my ass might it talks
into my lower back my back goes boom out
I've also bought dude you don't have you
have a good but it's not true it's true
you have a bad lower body who cares know
what we're gonna do that dude I can't
believe I'm [ __ ] still sick with it
you hit you suffer from allergies that's
all it is dude that's what I thought you
have a weakness that's cuz you're
la-born a raisin no I'm not my late born
and raised live on [ __ ] white
adventures
I'm from [ __ ] New Jersey you
understand me what do you eat now a few
changes you change your diet a little
bit obviously look at my [ __ ]
physique dunno dude um you know what
I'm shredding no you're not I'm [ __ ]
shredded what do you it's ridiculous no
are you lifting I'm doing a lot of core
[ __ ] I'm doing a lot of [ __ ] I'm
doing a lot of uh what do you call it I
got a trainer come over your house I
used to not what to call this stuff I
[ __ ] make it I might if I made it my
own dude I do a lot of gym yeah I do
crunch like I'm gonna say like I need to
sign some [ __ ] autographs is that my
workout come on man damn it
no but I do I go to the gym and I
[ __ ] I do a lot I like circuit
training and [ __ ] I do a lot of box
jumps I do a lot of [ __ ] kettlebells
I [ __ ] kill it I love it do it nah I
love it I love it not you not you're not
like a workout oh I'm not no oh I'm not
no oh yeah right dude on my membership
it says what the [ __ ] it's him that's
metal
yeah that's why Merson no that's not
true that's not true man let me see what
time it is Oh
okay cool that's a good thing to do on
this podcast hey guys welcome to the
segment let's see what time it is
we've been doing this for 44 minutes so
when you come up when you're on when
you're on this show when you're on our
show but Brendan is hosting you right
yeah when you're doing our show yeah but
Brendan is a guest host huh
what do you guys talk about what do you
guys talk about if you don't have a
[ __ ] star-studded guest which
obviously is what has helped you guys
then with that being said II well I
never thanked you for that I know but
you talk about life we talk about [ __ ]
that doesn't have to do with us no you
expand our horizon and then you bring up
a boring-ass book you're trying no we
talk about yeah we talk about reading
and and sport politics oh my god dude
things that matter in the world not not
about just killing it let me tell you
something and come guys want to talk
about something you guys want to [ __ ]
get away from all this [ __ ] you come
on down to congratulations with crystal
no no what do you do my partner's your
morning you woke up at what time I
actually woke up at 8:30 dude and and
did what I went and I had a meeting when
did and then what did you have for
breakfast and what did you have
just eggs eggs with some basil and
tomatoes in it not bad
killing it okay and then and you iced
Americanos and then I got another right
oh yeah dude you know I do a coffee all
day I go coffee all day shots shut you
let song shots shots shots shots shots
shots yeah that's about me and my
[ __ ] ass brother how many espressos
do you have a day well okay I guess
there's two in Americanos two or three
so uh seven seven what do you have for
lunch typically the same thing I'm sure
no I have uh like maybe tuna or yeah or
like a rice bowl maybe
yeah brown rice killing it yeah you know
something like that and then I know you
have late night late night I go dice
with your friend I go ham you you go
that place to that place with my friends
man I'd every night
not every night but I get a chicken
sandwich uh and [ __ ] fries
that's what I party that's it huh that's
what I [ __ ] party chicken sounds in
yeah I get a breakfast salmon
and I [ __ ] bar you know what I envy
about you what you don't really you
don't really bother yourself with the
issues of the world I I think about it
dude
I mean I what what can you do what can
you do I definitely you know I was
thinking about the other day like for
real like being actually real like you
know with this stuff that's going on
with the kids and all that now they're
being ripped from their families and
[ __ ] yeah like I don't want that to
happen right every part of me doesn't
want that to happen right and then
beyond that what do you do what do you
do
yeah that's see that that that that
feeling of not being able to do anything
as an individual is very real yeah I
mean I said but what you can do is
understand how that happened sure I'd
vote and yeah or just understand how and
why it happened right but then how it
can happen again and then you can kind
of you can make enough noise to assure
put it but I know I understand it's it's
like you kids like and then people and
then things go up on Instagram where
it's like call this number leave a
message and say the yada yada yada and
you're like okay but is this [ __ ] so
but the problem with apathy and and that
is that so it's almost like why should I
follow the rules well because the social
contract cuz it simplifies things
because human beings are very
complicated right so that's why you
that's why you followed the rules that's
why we have rules yeah
and so in a way you know it's kind of
like the same reason you don't litter
even though if I throw a piece of paper
out the window is it really gonna make a
difference in the big scheme of things
from when you're flying over LA no right
but it makes a difference because it's
it's it makes a difference it's a mind
small it's just a mindset that isn't it
somebody say yeah but it makes a
difference it's more like if you open
for me nobody's there for you right who
the audience yeah right so ha nobody's
there for you now I don't open for you
right now but if you did don't open
nobody would be people will be like even
if people were like oh yeah that guy was
funny as soon as I got onstage people be
like
who was that I'm gonna sell out in
Portland this weekend
by the way tomorrow helium then two
shows Friday to Saturday at helium in
Portland get your tickets now because
Chris Thalia is there's a good chance
and there's a rumor but it's a strong
one that Chris Lee is gonna know good
I'm not doing that and I'll tell you
this you're gonna be there no I won't
and I'll tell this much good if you're a
fan of me
and you're in the Portland area don't go
okay that's what I weigh Matic it and
here's the other thing to thank if
you're a real fan fly on over to [ __ ]
Tulsa or Midwest City in Oklahoma and
[ __ ] c'mon am I gonna good okay
alright dude that's where I am that's
why I'm gonna be this weekend Oklahoma
what club cuz you know dude did you say
club
alright dude are you in a theater no no
couldn't be good I you better watch your
[ __ ] man
no I'm doing a theater toria except for
I'm in Houston next month and I will be
doing the club the he's an improv yeah I
haven't done in a while I like to use I
like Houston you do yeah I know
know everyone's like in this summer [ __ ]
it bro I like being hottest [ __ ] people
are like you live in LA it what about
seasons I'm like oh you mean just it has
the best seats all your ready five and
breezy all gone then I [ __ ] and I try to
put on their face of bomb it away don't
you [ __ ] in your hand and throw it I
said play while I do it
I'm just disrespectful dude you're super
disrespectful but I'm real smart right
now we can both agree on that right I
don't know if that's true I live a life
a play dude you don't read a I do read
them I read articles and I also read
some books what do you read give me a
book you read okay hit the client with
John John Grisham now I happen to know
for a fact I asked you that question I
asked you what you read ten years ago
and you go the client hikes a the Chris
I go you got to read because I know dude
but it's so hard oh no no you need I
want you to read some book I do
the car no in life is not just about
crushing and know I know but junker Sean
is good writer yeah you know you look
it's so dumb your mouth is open no I I
do read I just don't like to talk about
the night's arts as I die for can start
to sound like I know more [ __ ] I'm not
sure I like it'll blow over you smart
like you you're always trying to [ __ ]
you know what I mean like showcase how
[ __ ] smart don't like your course the
air in front of you like that
that's I was trying to showcase how
[ __ ] smart and worldly on crystal
semia like a video sometimes I'll just
get a video of his hand like in it like
all his fingers pushed together and his
thumb rubbing that his fingers going
well if that's so like I would beat you
otherwise because you're my young um
you're young yeah he chris is so
disrespectful fit everybody including
his friends his friends there he
introduced them like this he's just my
sidekicks the guys in the movie with hey
sidekicks whatever your names are say hi
he's got there they're in movies hey all
you guys in a movie with five lines do
you know what's what's well maybe one of
funniest things you ever did was when
you we were at the comedy store and you
[ __ ] rolled up and I mean this was
years ago but they were like I guess
they were like I don't know if there
were all girls might have been some guys
but you showed up and we were all
everyone was talking there like a few of
us talking and and you just grabbed like
these guys and girls like not grab him
but you put your arms around him like
they were like they were asking for a
picture but they weren't you're like
yeah go ahead take it like that's how
you entered [ __ ] room oh my god it did
I that all the time I love that [ __ ]
I love stupid now I love doing that like
just assuming that you're the man it's
so funny dude he's coming buddy thank
you that's well the reason we get along
so much that's the best it's the best to
do that to basically I think my favorite
thing about life is to just make a
mockery of the insanity cuz it's a
circus and if that that's the thing it's
like nobody's really doing anything that
now especially now it's like the
Internet
it's like everyone just talk talk talk
talk yeah [ __ ] you let's just want to be
I want to escape dude you know I do this
you know my other podcast which does not
call the Bryan Callen show we we have
fun really smart people but my buddy
Hunter was like hmm we have to be
careful that like when we're talking
about problems it just becomes about
smart talk hmm and nothing what does it
look like in the real world like I'll
talk to really smart academics will
write books and they have these ideas
and seven I'm like okay good
what's that look like in the real world
like can I can i implement that and yeah
and are we solving a problem that's
actually tangible and measurable or are
we just well I'll tell you what having a
conversation I'll tell you what you're
not well you know what I mean because
I'm guy with a podcast but I will tell
you this much
don't have a friend named hunter and why
would we do that because now that is a
noun that is not necessarily AI name
right that would be if my name was video
game it would be like my name is I want
you to call hunter from now on I want
you to call him
video games last name is what Mott's
mots okay I'm out of here hi mom it's
Dutch yeah well I'll tell you what I in
Dutch Minh yeah well you better be a
giant Dutch man because I'll tell you
what with a name like hunter mots yeah
you gonna need to defend yourself yeah
no he's his brain is huge but he can't
he's not a fighter
I challenge him no yeah well do you guys
fighting would be interesting cuz it
would look like it would almost look
like a guy if you took if you took two
dudes yeah wait a minute I'm just not
trying to be but I'm just saying right
if you took two guys to big kind of
doughy guys no I'm not dough you're Joey
I'm I'm taut you're not that taught
you're taught with a layer of bumpy
dough over do it
ha yeah with no lies now listen have you
took YouTube don't get your job I got
tear drop the tear drop I don't know
about that anyway go ahead striations
for it would look like if you put you
guys together in a large cage a large
large metal box and then you had cameras
on the middlin inside the metal box and
then you'll addled the metal box back
and forth so you guys were falling into
each other like
haha and try not to fall into each other
that's what that's what it would look
like if you guys fought what the [ __ ]
dude you I've trained five [ __ ] six
years do and you would still bat the air
in my direction that's not cool dude bat
the air if I grab the hold yeah yeah you
have a tough time you know tough time
nah I just got if this boy from Jersey
grabbed a whole ship you're not from
Jersey
I am from your you coddled meat from
Pasadena I'm not from passing I never
lived in Pasadena I moved out here when
I was 12
even the [ __ ] rough streets of Jersey
no oh no you lived by coined the term
dirty you grew up in Pasadena in mansion
that's not true walking yata first of
all okay well your mind but jelly in
your mouth everything sent you off with
a pat on the ass in your lunch pail
that's create a mess huh this is what
what does he mean and chin are into
kratom which is actually an addictive
drug Brendan's not into it anymore well
dogs not he got vertigo from it so he
found out that that's the reason why he
had vertigo oh really
yeah I saw the fans stay away from it he
said that yeah I wonder if he knows that
that's what caused it cuz he's won he
was off of it he said that's when I
disappeared well almost immediately
wow it's so cool to be into things every
now and then you don't do any job
[Applause]
what dude Booton punked punk
yeah hey hey look wills got a [ __ ] 3
gallon jug of oh no it's me hang out
don't mind me
do you interview guys oh yeah wouldn't
you say that yeah ok alright but you
gotta admit we [ __ ] got you right
Chris uh yeah I didn't even glasses off
I didn't know you were coming alright
but I didn't know you're coming so yeah
let's regroup here ok so but pretty good
you gotta admit right sure it's pretty
good I don't mean to like get in on your
nose ok well you are talking about a
[ __ ] thing little bit of escapism is
dude I don't like to [ __ ] talk about
the ship a bride didn't drink his
[ __ ] boat yeah because he's us cuz
he's a sweet tart tart and ass that's no
I know because I have survived beautiful
strawberry and doc did I talk to will
like will that whole thing down you guys
trying to fight it well he by I know he
was joking around with you both have
yeah no no oh it's like the strawberries
all sweeter than in nature cause of the
surgery right yeah what do you get well
what do you been up to
don't worry about me [ __ ] interview
Chris well I've been doing that on boy
have you interviewed each other enough
on podcast
you don't know him yet yeah for the
sound effect for how he's doing like his
life yeah and he did a similar thing
that you do where he went oh really why
like well white minds think likes yeah
right well what do you what's the sound
great minds think just sound the fact
for your life bro how lime is usually
like in 1940 yeah I know that I know
that the audience can see it from the
back it's more impressive from the back
okay okay right and boppin nation yeah a
piece of animation oh wow and then now
fireballs
no oh it blew up the Sun the guy who's
gonna catch the ball oh that's your
sound effect yeah yep
that's an amazing getting it out of the
park yeah no I was very visual so far
than it went to this one audible it was
yeah man what are these drugs no no no
freedom [ __ ] is that those you found oh
there's none in there talking ways what
it is is honestly oh yeah Brendon and
Brian are dumb right right so so they're
technically dumb right so so what'd they
do that entail if you're dumb so what
this is what they do is a guy yes some
I just anyone let's say will be like hey
there's a new thing let's say um ingest
it right and it's good for your health
and so they go nah never mind man who
cares let's see no exactly
let's do a little improv I'll be the guy
who be you okay I'll be okay this is
what so normally okay who are you sir
sorry I'm just some guy there's a new
thing and it's out and you should ingest
it oh no thanks
go [ __ ] yourself okay all right yeah
right that's how it goes when right now
now I'll do Brian
okay yeah hey man what's up yeah yeah
I'm just I'm good man how are you they
just are you I know yeah no I'm god I am
some guy because I don't think I've ever
seen you before
no you wouldn't have them do some guys
so there's a new thing you should get it
and you should ingest it give me all of
it okay
can you talk about it on your pod
hundred producers and I hope it makes
you do well yeah it makes you money yeah
and I will be your test subject
okay that's a gross now four months
later I have psoriasis
[Laughter]
what gave you so [ __ ] lovely when he
says when the guy says hey have that and
wash it down with that get psoriasis
yeah oversimplification is it
we're so glad that we're getting bang
like what's that means feel oh yeah it
is do your father still know who Theo is
I've never met Leon feel 1va ugh that's
how you separate the OVA and you bastard
it via Vaughn we just got Theo mad wait
he's in the next studio mastering his
podcast
Oh worked around him out yeah you know
what we're drowning them out with - no
and then the call Chris Chris has veins
in his head you know what that means I
can always vascular it means that
something's gonna pop and you're gonna
die well we all are one day I don't know
what death is to quote the great
whatever rapper said this Santini you
can Oh death is just the moment that
dying ends well I hate that book that's
a great rap you're gonna die here remain
his name escapes me right now eyes don't
look no one Tom although more like funky
comedy or whatever you gotta get the he
makes peep in jest this saying you get
horny yeah yeah that's a good tongue
yeah I've been working on some of my
oh man I do so precious ready to hear
some tone loke
yeah well that's wow thing that's good
it's you know what I like how what you
captured is how insecure tone locust
yeah yeah funky cold yeah he's one of
the most insecure rappers yeah thanks
for the memory what are you doing back
in LA jack don't worry about me man okay
so I can do your thing hey I get my shot
Chris and apparently your hometown you
know Chris and I [ __ ] lit it up New
York in New York who your big city a
dream that's right oh-ho I get this from
from will as I'm I mean I just get this
hey let's slow it down - rich yeah dude
we don't need girl a bus can't have a
conversation get this I get no good all
right you suck me off yeah I get I just
landed in LA I'm too tired to say it an
Italian say something I don't like I'll
slap you around
nice yeah see that was the me right
feeling that I had when I land
dude I was in New Jersey in New York
Chris what a movie yeah I was doing a
movie Chris Chris was in town we hung
out we went we [ __ ] we did it we ate
steaks pasta yeah we have possibly got
it without a car we got a cannoli do you
get it oh we went to that clear
staircase in Times Square we took some
pictures so got it right not a picture
with Ironman yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ]
smelly Ironman who's coming apart at the
same dose a picture a [ __ ] of portly
ayran man yeah and also [ __ ] Wario
there was a big warrior and it's a big
yellow Mario yeah yeah there was a big
Wario big [ __ ] Porto Rican gentleman
with it was had a Wario Mario who you
playing in this movie some guy they know
I'm not bring some guy oh maybe if he's
playing some guy you could give him
something to ingest come on
no dude I have a question for you Brian
you know what and do you want to hear
the specials here or did you just feel
like getting a good old-fashioned Grand
Slam piping hot all-american [ __ ]
slam you're an ass whoopin I'll tell you
this much
I'd appreciate 25 minutes ago yeah and
it's here and I'm not moving disrespect
and I don't give a [ __ ] dude that's how
much I know are you with me sweating
diapers nope I'm not even wearing
underwear oh and I have a hole in my
jeans I can see it right now yeah what
up the Eamonn I only reason it's not
slipping over the end of that chairs
because he's making an indent right he's
sitting in there I'm doing what's doing
why is it why is it bone white did you
eat did you swallow a hamster no I wish
it's white it's white little Krusty's
like a dog stealing a goose goose that's
a mess along it's been thrown green
wanna leave [ __ ] is so it's ivory white
bro yeah why should I every wife but my
snaky
are you ingesting bones no you just you
you you you have you would have a snake
for real though I used to I used to have
a Burmese pythons dude I was an
eccentric kid and I always loved
serpents I've always loved serpents yeah
dude how about how did you see the guy
who was getting choked by the [ __ ]
snake because he he rescued it and he
was trying to take selfies with it no no
he almost died he was like he was
getting so serious it was an in it was
like in really India or something in
trouble or any or something like yeah it
was so it was like he was it was so
scary like Italy terrifying I tweeted
about it if you can't find it that's the
guy yeah oh my goodness
that's a man that's called a Burmese
pythons obviously in India that's it
that's a Burmese python but and and I
believe look at that I'm almost sure
that's a Burmese python it sounds like
something that could happen okay look at
that really that look yeah how terrified
would you be there a video of it yeah
there it's not fun yeah there is
I'd [ __ ] [ __ ] right there to be
brutally honest I mean I just poop he'll
you take the tail and you start peeling
and you'll be fine oh really
yeah dude that's crazy you're so smart
when it comes to Thank You Man thank you
that's a Burmese python that's what I
had hey bright shut up exactly what I
had why did you have that because I
there me and he got so [ __ ] mean he
was so mean today he would bite and I
just was into it
now they're freaking the snake out
because they're idiots and see that
snake is getting scared and he's holding
there yeah you don't know that just be
hungry I'm an amateur herpetologist he's
squeezing that head too much now he's
shaking the head now it gets crazy oh
wait no it doesn't even get crazy until
I think he starts walking away but look
at the hero that helps him look at that
that's cool
yeah Brian would be [ __ ] himself in
the corner I was composing a popsicle
skit that wasn't doing [ __ ] damn bro in
one second that thing would have [ __ ]
wrapped around is just such a police guy
Toki got they've been around snakes I do
it in the India dude what was India like
it was I was doing Europe Europe you
know what the chera hard-hitting in
you you really are why don't I interview
you guys okay all right sure hey what's
up
welcome to fighter and kid I'm sitting
in for Brian and Brendan here with
Bryant here but Chris is here also okay
hey got a lot going on around today
these guys are doing comedy and doing
all sorts of stuff in in the business
and show business at large yeah
Brian one of these on the table that's
it you're so what how'd you get started
in comedy where we being a [ __ ]
smartass breaking everyone's balls and
yeah no I mean family and your friends
and then you're like I'm funny right I
mean he'll be the same thing for you
right now actually me undies it's not
just a part of the Monday's famine no
look you got burlap underwear what you
got no I I have oh you can't wear any
underwear no I don't make fun of me
about my see your dick let's see what
your work we pull out what ifs right
okay that's great
yeah cuz I used to model for them when I
was in the nineties I got mud I have one
DS I wear mostly Mondays okay what are
you wearing k don't know God you would
just have another legs you would there's
a Kirkland don't dude yank them out
you're wedging yourself your balls are
getting old
hey do do all seriousness you're a big
guy with a powerful lower body in you
when you're when you're gonna make love
and yeah the girls like here comes this
big guy yeah and then then you pull out
that that's sad knob what what what does
the girl go oh no no what happens is
thing nope she looks at me and I get
undressed and she goes well that all
makes perfect sense all right but what
she doesn't understand is that I'm it's
scaled to me but then as I get closer
it's like whoa no I'm seven foot five
and Y 872 pounds so that yeah yeah I
think and then what are you and then
when it gets closer then it looks like
an overstuffed [ __ ] one of those
sandwiches
the regulated get from Jersey Mike's
yeah the kind of you're gonna do Jersey
Mike yeah I got a Jersey money except
flaps of skin just kind of hanging on
yeah that's [ __ ] you got a cocked and
they make it Mike's way yeah the end of
my dick looks like a handful of baloney
just what a different force because I'm
European I got it I got a cut more to
make it shape like a rose that's pretty
good I got it all got a Utah visited I
got body modifications as a baby yeah
piercing that's keeping my balls very
small yeah pearls under the skin yeah
pearls it's beautiful I feel bad about
coming and you know saying like I feel
bad about like coming here and then
being like oh yeah that's very good
actually to think of that yeah yeah
because you you do you do something and
then feel bad about it is what are you
well we like here here rather have you
here than not Bieber today man it's
awesome you know they're making a
surprised you believe his face when it
happened yeah well he was like what yeah
I mean I was surprised but ya think that
we got you we were thinking about it we
talked about it all guess what like
yesterday yeah we want yeah that's what
I didn't even know that you were in town
so W surprised yeah and I flew back into
town because you're [ __ ] so New York
dude dude I'm so New York I'm so [ __ ]
New York it's not true Chris Chris I was
in New Jersey and I was making a film
but I was right close to the city the
the bad apple the big yeah city of
shoulders man row and everybody was and
and so Chris I got to visit Chris while
he was in town yeah and then he went and
did this Chris count how many times he
gets recognized oh you know what I can't
touch it Tom yeah I wear a baseball hat
and sunglasses and nobody literally
literally people are like I know I'm
from somewhere but yeah I don't normally
see that guy with a hat sunglasses on so
it can't be him yeah I hear people
saying that have you ever heard about
have you ever heard about the people
living underneath the subway yeah mole
people yeah
in New York there's people in the in the
whole community yeah well there's well
there's different subway tunnels yeah
that the trains don't go down anymore so
a lot of people who are homeless have
set up these cardboard cities down where
they deserve and it's black juice hey
it's not what no don't
hey man today don't derail yeah it was
gonna be so awesome I think oh I knew
that yeah you knew that I knew it yes I
know a lot about comedy but there's Ryan
but when someone's teeing something up
and they [ __ ] take the tea and it
says anecdote on the tea exactly and
then they take a ball and it says like
punch line and also underneath in
parenthesis says take it or leave it
not a huge deal yeah but but yeah right
and they put it on top of the tea and
there's a batter right and there's a
battery about of you and it batters me
and I come up and I'm [ __ ] showing my
underwears you yeah hey a very
established comedic actor thank you very
much guys is hilarious and it's
appreciate actor I appreciate it hey you
know what and you'd figure oh also by
the way hey Nona mwah Wow guys this is a
conversation no this is my job drop it
sitting with a couple of funniest people
on the planet now he knows you too right
the [ __ ] I do know so now if you were
just gonna tell like a story or
something yeah maybe he'd say all right
I'm gonna sit over here I'm gonna have a
smoke break a little while or are you
gonna come up with something that makes
no sense just is not relevant that they
deserve
yeah but it talks it in dude dude what
you took a [ __ ] bowl of spaghetti and
yet dumped it out onto that baseball on
the team yeah and and the reason why I
say that is you might be like oh that
makes no sense yeah that's exactly my
point
no what you do yeah make
knows okay man your this is my show
never mind with high school remind you
guys you took a bullet pasta you're
interrupting it into the [ __ ]
baseball no no and now and now as you're
explaining it to him he's saying no I
understand and it won't happen again
and he's got a bucket of chocolate ice
cream and he's dumping it onto the pots
and ashing it into the plate with his
foot while he's telling you I know that
I dropped this brother pasta on the
ground dude but at least maybe we could
pick tell me about the model have some
okay I was all I was gonna say was that
I went down there and it was very very
dark and I still got recognized of
course that didn't happen of course not
had it been in the moment that you were
doing it could have been amusing could
have been funny
not only that could have lead it led to
some other stuff yeah isn't that right
can it now no it can't get it so what
did we learn
Bry I not join you're putting your hands
in your lap I'm not your [ __ ] student
you guys are my guests I'm uncomfortable
with the fact I'm here sitting here in
the tea phadke studios the the show has
been so successful that when you know
your shows been successful when your
logo has been turned into some sort of
like bathroom tile you know there's so
many entrances it new you know what I
will say what if they were very
successful
this wouldn't be broken I got a stick up
for Brian here that is that is the style
yeah that's not fair dude you're being
unfair right now it's broken like all
those are not those let's like a tile
work things it's our thing yeah yeah no
it's not broken but I'll tell you I'll
tell you if you've got a studio where
there's all sorts of there's a really
cool like what would this be steampunk
this this would be I made us that clock
a guy sent us a guy sent you that claw
yes
no I didn't know you knew Gargamel it's
a little goth yes it's pretty cool I
think I saw yeah [ __ ] boring it isn't
that crazy I saw this clock in a
Rammstein video 94 but you've got all
sorts of cool stuff in here that tells
everybody that you guys are established
and it's a it's a very successful
podcast and still you know little about
combo and then crazy right that's so
crazy no broken glass side collage as my
whole life [ __ ] was that Brides career
all dude you're gonna think unless
you're [ __ ] knocked over one of us
you ain't it better than that no this is
better look at the way he's sitting this
is better come on look at the way he's
[ __ ] sitting there so I got a guy man
do you sit cover you're [ __ ] for real
[ __ ] it don't don't sit like that god
yes it's so umm feet comfy so
disrespectful is this it's respectful
because I'm using like you you've got me
and I'm being all as much of me as I can
be no I'm further soften it up here oh
reasonably brines videoing this when
there's seven cameras in here that's
pretty [ __ ] do I have to do that yeah
all right
will how long are you in LA for who
gives a [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] man you
guys both ask hard-hitting question okay
let's go to some some current events I
want to get their take on the world
oh well that Trump thing was one of them
he apparently signed or he's gonna sign
an executive order that doesn't allow
the families to be separated anymore
well that they talked about this earlier
yeah I heard about this yeah so that way
that's that yeah that's really good it's
an old law that should should never have
been encountered in this way there's
absolutely no excuse for taking children
away from parents so let's all shut up
about it and make sure it's good now so
everyone can shut up about it so that we
can have
a ground-floor that is parents and
children together
well I've never heard of not unless so
that everyone can say hey guess what
it's better we know it's better to have
the children we know that unless you're
in the orphanage business well unless
you're the orphanage business yes it's
not it shouldn't be a business we do
have to take into account that the
orphanages it hasn't been the orange
business takes a hit no I can that they
can give off Ryan it's terrible enough
no no Brian
it's absolutely heinous to have the
children away from the parents to begin
with I just launched it and never been
never even of even existed I hear and
anytime that happens it's bad yes
further the suffering well no let's keep
in mind that orphanages are take look
hey all I'm saying dude I've been
everywhere okay I've been everywhere
really but no I've been everywhere hey
dude give them it give them Jacksonville
it's Jax give them Jackson we'll give
the families and the kids give Jackson
five let me tell you something Jackson
will [ __ ] sucks donkey balls [ __ ]
you've been through Jacksonville a few
times I would imagine in your travels do
here Albany right I did I'll tell you
one thing man yeah it sucks [ __ ]
donkey [ __ ] man yeah it's not the North
or the South it's like what the [ __ ] get
it together
Jacksonville hey oh you got a wholefoods
congratulations man rolling your eyes
dude I'm playing Jacksonville and I'm
playing Jacksonville coming up in the
fall guess what I know it starts donkey
balls I'm still gonna [ __ ] man at that
point I'll already have their money
personally sold a bunch of day yeah but
let them have Jackson let him have
places you Dayton okay no hi you know
I've been it's a legit town sir there's
no hi Oh separated by a river
yeah oh hi Oh River probably that sounds
familiar
Delaware give him half of it
Delaware Delaware is not big enough
Calloway know why kids need room why cuz
what about donkey balls dachshund what
what about the donkey balls Jackson
it sucks um I don't know another seller
sucks those balls nah they're cool
places I'm kidding either so that's we
all know I joke that's your answer I
went to Tampa Bay once and I didn't get
near the bay and I could have been
anywhere yeah that's a good story in
July
what's earned thanks for solving this
problem what's our next current event so
the current events are I don't know why
there's just terrible stories everywhere
so do you guys know a rapper named xxx
yeah so he was shot and killed while
trying to buy more site yesterday right
motorcycle yeah he was only 20 years old
you know this guy I don't know he
apparently all the artists think he's
like one of the best talents out there
super inspired by sucks yeah um well uh
I'm pretty well versed in his music the
guy was a real talent really like a real
the real deal real talent yeah
however he was and and like an awful guy
oh yeah like like and like there would
have been like some expose days on him
that is just like his ex-girlfriend like
he was very depressed right he was yeah
he was yeah he was and he was just I
mean you know damn well all I'm saying
is like the whole believe women movement
is a great thing and if you do believe
women then yeah then this guy was a real
awful oh okay so it's it's a weird thing
you know to think about because the
artist separating the artists and what
he's done
artistically with well what do you
actually that's a good like woody Ryan
seen everyone in Roman Polanski's movies
yeah like so if somebody's a ghastly
human being but makes incredible art
that still means you can whether are
right but does he make incredible art or
does he just kind of busy just kind of a
ghastly human being who well Savo know
part head over here
and don't dismiss me with your hand like
that don't all in my direction buddy
what what but not my sound effect no
yeah it is no but he wasn't he will he
honestly his music was really [ __ ]
good man I know but then and I'm not now
look if all that [ __ ] it sucks that it
does suck because he was like well I
don't want to then I don't want to
support the guy he's also 20 he's also
[ __ ] up he's also depressed it doesn't
mean he can't change and all that still
it still sucks out you know but what
what so with today no anything else he
was buying the motor secondly I shot it
well apparently the guy was shot and
robbed because he was posting you know a
lot of these rappers are like you know
they're flaunting what they have so
apparently he was like I'm going to the
motorcycle shop right now to buy [ __ ]
motorcycle with cash
this is what I heard and and he had a
Louboutin bag on him and they'd [ __ ]
pulled up on him robbed them shot him in
his car and [ __ ] robbed him yeah okay
see that's what's up that is so [ __ ]
up and that sort of isn't that
interesting how social media another
evil another directive evil a direct
evil that can come from it you can get
shot and killed because you're flossing
well I know people yeah and also and
also the the the thing I mean it's just
it's it's it's like that lifestyle too
well if you're a black male in this
country you're like something like 25
times or some crazy amount more likely
to die than anybody else but I just it's
like the house and the car like Brian's
[ __ ] stat also I love talking about
stats yeah yeah Brian by going with the
stats but bailed on it yesterday but
it's just for it just it's you know what
guys well I like hanging with you guys I
get I like coffee two of the funniest
guys and then everyone was and a good
time with drunk guy you're driving next
row next current event with this [ __ ]
water guzzling ok so we talked about the
Chris Hardwick heart
hardwick story on Monday and Brendon
mentioned that I guess his girlfriend
did his ex-girlfriend did text him a lot
before you know this story came out that
she wanted to reconcile the texture out
now this is basically all her texts and
he didn't respond to her at all this is
after they broke after he broke up with
her oh this was okay hey will I be ever
happen we both handle this poorly
possibly myself more so I'm sorry I
shouldn't have texted you I think I just
got caught up in a wave all the things
are awesome with you seven months after
the split mmm interesting but now she's
now she wrote that thing well that's
what I said as I said it's one thing to
confront somebody like you know
personally but when you go when you go
public with that letter you are it's
it's a revenge piece you are trying to
hit them where they live you're actually
trying to publicly shame them and ruin
their career that's a fact and just just
at least at least be honest with that if
you want if you want to destroy somebody
that's what you're trying to do it's not
about closure it's not about you it's
threatening the right ear you do that
just like yeah one-on-one with somebody
when you when you out somebody in the
public square like that it's not for me
yeah it's not something I respecting I
just don't and also seven months later
you're still trying to get back together
with them but now what what about that
wait this is seven months after that
they've been apart for yeah so what
about that like Kim I don't understand
and also you were with him for three
years I if he was if he was that way
where is your role in it don't you have
a responsibility to walk the [ __ ] away
and if you didn't shouldn't you today
next time I will and that was on me at
the end of the day after three years
it's interesting right now man it's
really interesting
I mean it's [ __ ] interesting you can
just come out and say here these bad
[ __ ] because it happened and then
yeah he got dinged by these companies
drop you write a lot about that's
problematic but look the you know
emotional abuse is a real course it is
of course of course I know you know that
but but but you know I don't know what
to think of this Chris Hardwick thing I
I mean you usually hear stuff about it I
had no idea that this this was like I
never heard anything like this about
Chris
yeah so I'm not saying that that means
it's not true I have no [ __ ] idea
I don't know why a woman would I just
don't know I think all of us behave in
certain ways and relationships and there
are times in those relationships but
neither party wants anybody to know
about it because we don't I have I have
acted opponent ly with my own wife the
mother of my children in fights and said
[ __ ] that I didn't mean but no one would
ever hear that because I've heard you on
several occasions now not to make light
of the situation tell her let's not talk
in public at restaurants as everybody
recognizes me you see that's what Brian
says because we'll be hanging at Brian's
house inside the house before a few
people go out for dinner and he'll say
[Music]
mr. calamy right and you also have the
thing where you say let's do you tell
her like do the Japanese and what you
mean is walk 10 feet behind me when I
walk well do the jet that's what I call
you say do the Japanese [ __ ] heart yeah
and she stands there as you keep walking
now you know it's interesting sometimes
you go for dinner and then you have your
evening constitutional afterwards and
sure the men may be walking behind as
the women are forward or vice versa I do
that it just means the guys want to
catch up right but I know the scenario
that Chris is talking about here and
because it was a dinner that the four of
us attended was three and your wife yes
and still she had to do the Japanese
remember yeah we were walking through
the room walking down Abbot Kinney chris
loves to go he recommended the
restaurant I love this is a lie Chris
you've never been to a restaurant in a
bikini
what restaurant was it I was some
Italian dude it was that one word useful
really nice you know I don't you guys
with gorgonzola you and I just went
regular I got the [ __ ] thing we need
a pink sauce cuz you do I can't beat
that kind of can't [ __ ] beat that get
like a nice vodka song says you're
assassinating my character and then
after
I had I had a lovely I had had a fennel
salad it was lovely
I had fennel and it was just a little
cracked and then you and then after that
I was like you know what I've been
hearing about it yeah I'll have some
mutton I'm gonna have the mutton here
and they have the sides that usually
wrap around with a monkey chop right and
they Flay them out it's the bacon cut
and they call them the ear my wife my
wife wasn't permitted to eat right yeah
after we finished we were walking or
taking a walk to where the cars were and
you said sweetheart you go like this
remember yeah and she said you want me
to and then you finish her sentence and
said do the Japanese and then she walked
ten feet behind us from blocks and
blocks yeah I'm old fashioned yeah while
you talked about stock yeah and you know
what you mentioned I know what you
mentioned stats combat stats I'm all fat
you mentioned inner-city stats from
Chicago and you started talking about
here's some gun violence [ __ ] you have
no [ __ ] right you don't know anything
about that you've never lived there and
you're chiming in double X you don't
know I like [ __ ] X guys everyone's
gonna be like Brian you don't know [ __ ]
you know no and so we don't know yet
yeah happen Chris Hardwick well anyway
yeah it's gonna be good wait I listen
here's what we got to do all right
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
get through this no here's what's up
because everyone's like okay you know
look here's you know I don't think
anybody wants anyone to deal with the
likes of you know ah this is old news to
give a [ __ ] and been around for a
[ __ ] year this whole thing but the
[ __ ] you know Harvey Weinstein's of
the world than that okay so I think
we've got all everyone who can
societally understand the difference
between good and bad cool now we got all
this [ __ ] let's have a different news
channel for it we're just a news channel
that does this yeah we've got me to
stuff yep
well there's a difference me to stuff
and then there's a difference between I
just feel like any time if you're gonna
air gun
into that like this it's unfortunate for
everyone you know things are gonna fly I
don't know I was just kind of like going
and that's [ __ ] why you know what
that wasn't even going to be coming I
kind of did I kinda did toss it up to
unify know what I'm talking about it
balance stand up god it you'd be
hard-pressed to find something funnier
than Callens to stand up
except for Callen when he's Syrian
[Applause]
Callen coming to town this weekend right
you'd be hard-pressed to find a funnier
guy unless he's being serious we'll be
right back for news weather traffic and
then you hear that you're like what the
[ __ ] were you guys no no no we're just
so you're here you're in this weekend a
couple minutes well I don't wanna tree
aliy gonna fly up and do okay yeah all
right yeah well I don't that's not
really Portland where they're shutting
where they're picketing
white owned white owned restaurants cuz
they're there they're cooking ethnic
food are they really yeah what oh yeah
what the point because if you're a white
owned if you're a white owner of a
restaurant but you're serving a fusion
of ethnic food no really appropriate
it's very more joy than that there sure
ain't this this burrito thing these two
white women who got New Mexico figured
out a way to make these amazing burritos
they were shut down cuz they were they
were appropriating Mexican culture
that's amazing well I know it's amazing
so then I'm shutting down your
performance in the hangover movies I'm
not Lebanese I'm sure there are
performances you were never that guy
that's what I missed that's acting
that's what I mean yeah I think it I'm
liberal though see yeah but you get so
like maybe I'm real that you don't even
the real deal yeah that's not what I was
trying to say I wasn't like what you're
saying thank you
oh don't thank me man I was trying to
say something about the way I wind
tragic news
Marina del Rey then he [ __ ] expired
and then he was so [ __ ] real about it
that the doctors Kidman did not Topsy
and said natural causes said I win I'm
35 remember the time we were talking
about the song to play he was you guys
dude number one hit
if I leave you I want to take this piece
of podcasting set it to music
yeah recipes Brian another single here
51 years old crushing and like I've said
before on many mediums well whatever
it's not that no no you want to find
well I was gonna save it I have it I
just gonna say about Brian 51 could beat
the living [ __ ] out of CM Punk 10 years
younger
thank you Ken no this guy Brian you
could beat CM Punk he could beat the
[ __ ] tar out of him I think really
yeah I want to see that all right in the
UFC one last fight I make he had what
was his name Mike Jackson yeah that's
the only reason I remember it I'm beat
I'll be Chris his ass I'll tell you that
much why don't you dress up like Sam
couldn't Chris all right a lot people
say I look like
here no because in his Corral the number
you could yeah I watched that fight
going okay so they just kind of throw in
he's an entertainer
yeah right he's a professional wrestler
you've been training for a couple years
to do something you know that's other
what's call that other yeah you're
primarily your ear you're an actor
you're a comedian you're you know
whatever the [ __ ] a nice player box and
so I'll say tennis player but I come off
the ground when I hit I mean the tops
been so stupid oh this is my general
song yep this is it
[Applause]
is that it though yeah it on this
that's my that's my funeral that you
feel so and Chris and I will come in are
you guys carrying my coffin we're gonna
be my floating next to your coffin like
this were the only pallbearers now I
want to be wrapped like a mummy and you
guys are carrying me wrapped like a
mummy yeah we're just making you float
yes sure my body's rigor mortis your
wife's crying yeah and then we do that
wink at my wife with my with me on your
shoulder wrapped in gauze you know you
know out here in LA in Southern
California they have those sign flippers
they have them other parts of the
country words like Subway sandwich 599 I
know these new apartments that's what we
do with Brian's corpse [ __ ] funeral
and we just float around and spin the
cake in suits yeah what do you serve
bacon to white women are gonna make
burritos
there you go there you go there you two
white women who went to Mexico are super
foodies hey you know what let's start a
restaurant to keep the [ __ ] loved it
yeah and now it opens just Walter
flippin Brian's body with chicken suits
on all white women make burritos White's
crying so hard yeah
and then I bust out of the gauze and I'm
like psych yeah both your throats okay I
drink your blood
no I'm tired today all right dude flew
around yesterday I'm tired today
all right on an airplane they kept
delaying it was that a new New York they
had that nor'easter I guess right I hate
the norm I yeah like that's just not
done don't say that right um I mean this
is what this podcast could just be a day
what a day long oh yeah yeah we should
keep going yeah it have any more current
events I don't bring any sad stuff bring
it up
well how about Starbucks closing 150
stores next year yeah they just closed
50 you know they usually just close 50
stores easier but it's three times too
many
they're just not we're doing well those
locations make there's also stories that
well I know it's crazy like how much
coffee can there's a night you know what
dude I swear to God I woke up the other
day I didn't realize there's a there's a
Starbucks in my guest room there's a
star but how did you not know wait a
minute I don't know it wait a minute so
they started like someone pay the
franchise fee and have you know what I
guess so this was yesterday there's no
he isn't just three employees people
crazy
other customers the other people
couldn't yes that because you don't go
around it you have a busier house he
said it's obviously very big wait how
many rooms in here how you know what
okay so bucks
okay so that's a Manor is that a manor
or is it a mansion don't look like you
don't know the answer to that have you
seen your being how about this what you
don't I'll let you know oh come on
you're the first of all you're never
gonna get back to us with that second of
all you [ __ ] don't mean it I'll look
at your hands
you're [ __ ] crooked mouth that's not
even a thing you do that is so not a
thing you do mother [ __ ] my thing I do
this a lot yeah you know
do that modest right now he's making a
WOD face
what's fork do you have a name for your
house is it a or is just an address
probably just a house you know it's got
it what well it's got like a CD on the
gate okay what what don't look at your
eyes again what is it you're so
expressive when you're lying you'd be on
the game no you don't have that look you
gonna be careful you're gonna flatline
again you're gonna die if you cannot do
it I'm fine dude right now cuz I feel
really good does your place how are you
gonna [ __ ] halo causes I lived too hard
he lived too much you do you have that
that blonde draft coffee that new
Starbucks they have that yeah it's
actually one of those Starbucks what if
I don't know what they call them Babs
trying to ask the employee Bob so it's
hard it's going to bed and cuz it's a 24
do they work for you Ted that's a [ __ ]
man just a some I know I should be
making some sort of money right yeah do
they you know what they might close but
I don't know do your studies have the
new like the new chicken tortilla egg
sous-vide do that yeah not just the
other two yes I think it in Gruyere and
there's yes they say they have the but
they're always out oh [ __ ] they're
always right he really has a Starbucks
in school too because if I don't have a
if I don't have a phone charger they
have those [ __ ] table chargers yeah I
can just go on and just place my phone
on there so you bet you had to know that
when you went in there you're like put a
Starbucks here and then this now do you
allow anybody in the Starbucks or is
there a they they yeah I mean yeah you
can let anybody in mostly I would say
it's it's mostly white people and okay
Wow why is it just why he was just
mostly white and who else that's a bonus
I'm not trying to I'm not trying to is
it are you saying that you have a white
only Starbucks
I don't care I'm not judging you all
right I know it and again it has nothing
to do with me it's in your home crystal
but in your house you've been saying
that yeah that's five minute I didn't I
didn't I didn't have a I didn't know
yeah yeah we got it we gotta talk about
your thing about a guy who's got it I
mean I've got a big house you know but
in a racist cop no no no no no no well I
don't have any but you do admit that
they did there is a Starbucks in my home
that's a cop I found out about that
yesterday about what that it's is it is
that why people only are there by
coincidence or is there a barrier to
entry to people who have more melanin in
their skin so I popped in about five or
six times this vicar's i I still every
time I was like wait a minute really and
I would walk in and I'd be like your
home yeah okay my home yeah and every
time I walk in maybe six seven eight
nine times so I had there were it was
pretty much white people don't only that
okay so wait so you're a sign or enjoyed
Starbucks so they do have signs yeah but
they have that sign that says Starbucks
and then they have a sign that says
things on this premises may cause cancer
and birth defects or whatever them and
then oh we can right we have the right
to refuse service to anyone and how much
of yeah you know that's not is there
anything there was there was small
wording under that which do you know
what that said under the wearies we
reserved a right to refuse service to
anyone and then a bunch of stuff under
that that was in parentheses did it say
of color it said something like because
when I got closer to the Sun yeah this
was small right yeah yeah but they were
like it's in no black oh boy Chris Chris
that's it's a super you have a young
white Silesians
and instead of four other can't have it
you have to change the sign that's it
that's a that's a mental that's a that's
a dream I have nothing to do you're
gonna be responsible for it no matter
why you bring this to any court in the
land the land will say you had it in
your house sir right right here's your
house words me judge I didn't know that
no no hold on your honor you do now and
here's the thing you don't judge you've
known for a day that you have a
whites-only room in your house it's not
a room at two Starbucks and I think
obviously Starbucks to be in a lot of
trouble let's call it a Starbucks it
doesn't matter if it's a rumor let them
come try walking my chin walks in with a
friend of his who happens to also be
Asian or let's say of Latin descent or
America what can what happens let's put
it this way I'll stop right there
chin doesn't walk in they have a I don't
want I mean III again yesterday I walk
in I'm noticing all this [ __ ] yeah
and they actually have a separate
entrance I was like oh my how annoyed I
know but Chris what happens when I walk
out and I'm like they already stopped
you when you walked in no no it's your
house but nobody stopped me now well you
look Albanian which is technically white
so there you have it so yeah so I walked
into the part you know you know the you
know when you walk into a bank and they
have the first entrance and then you
have to wait for them to have the light
turned green till we open up the second
entrance yeah okay so sort of so what
happens is no when when a bank gets
robbed if a bank is robbed there's two
entrances right and they're one after
another and the robber leaves the one
door and then they trap them in the
little area yeah to where they can't
leave the second door right
yeah okay yeah this Starbucks has a
version of that right so Chris what and
you can only make it no I'm saying it
has a it has no prob you passed the
first entrance but then he has to get he
goes into the he's in the chamber right
so now then what happens the tension
Center so another second entrance that
would be a red light for a fortune would
see a red light so these this is how
does it get his coffee well there's I
mean he's free to go anywhere else do
you want don't you have a racist goes up
set you guys want to get coffee no
that's from the white only star that's a
racist coffee you pay for this thing I
don't know so what together the name of
that dad what's with that terrain so it
has two names right so it has it's
called the simply strawberry okay and
then and then so they said so and and
then and then under it it says made by
made with real strawberry sugar fructose
whatever sorry it's a little red we wish
that it was these people hate everyone
but what it's dude this is [ __ ] up
this this is not gonna look good not
omiai saying that but don't matter stack
up one day no wrong in two rows just let
them in yeah I'm mad you wake up one day
you walk into a room yeah you're out you
haven't been down that corridor or
whatever they say sometimes I hand you
open up the door well no that doesn't
happen
trying to give you the benefit ya head
corridor that you had you see all of a
sudden a bunch of green and it's a
starbucks me like holy [ __ ] i had
nothing to do with this okay
that's where i'm coming from right it
happens to be I
apparently I'm realizing now a white
zone now you're realizing that Chris
you've known Fred a full day and you
still haven't taken action have you
talked to anybody about like in some
ways so I asked the guy who works there
right and I was like what's what's his
name oh so his name yeah his name is uh
his his name is Henry yeah yeah just a
regular name right yeah and so so I
asked him how did what's the deal with
this right and he goes like this
I don't have anything to do with it
nobody's responsible for this insanely
racist coffee shop Henry's a white guy
who did the who put the sign me not that
it matters but I think Henry might have
something to do it he's a white guy okay
but then you but you're also going I got
another
everybody's later anybody there let's
take responsibility for their insanely
race you said there were three people
yes three other get to other with you
other guy yeah Henry Zack that's right
Henry yeah white god I'm not even gonna
ask yet well
Henry yeah Cody Cody yes those guys are
white those are white Kody's young okay
yeah he's probably as those parents were
like yeah let's call them the exact poem
Jack brain which watch this well call
him a throwback name yeah yeah my
transatlantic guy so and then Cody and
sag yes and Zack and Zack is an older
man okay he doesn't wear the the green
the apron or whatever okay so he's the
man what is he with yeah sure he's a
medic what's he wearing so he's got all
sorts of other [ __ ] going on he
he might be the one no I don't you know
what I'm not sure because he's not even
wearing the Starbucks outfit what is he
wearing that's what we're saying so he
has like this
why Oh what go on [ __ ] go white top
is it a white just a white smock exactly
yeah yeah it's a smock is it to keep off
the coffee oh please it's in a red and
black oh wait is it a verb boy hold on
is it a robe yeah I mean maybe he just
okay a fetter he's a he's a Grand Wizard
does taste magical does he have little
symbols like on his would neck be next
to like oh you're and this is the Auto
Club and then there's like an emblem I
never read a black [ __ ] like those those
symbols symbols really so the [ __ ]
clan secretly open the Starbucks in the
Starbucks and they're profiting and you
have the Klan in your house you have you
probably probably gas him out of there I
was like guys I was like gasps about yes
there's a guy in the guy who can he
shoots a gas not gonna kill him but
it'll it's a noxious gas that will get
it they have that in the entryway it's
an anthem between the two entrance and
anti-racist gas they have the gas you
gotta get a guy in there okay let me
tell you - I was like what this is
illegal and they go like this dude here
don't worry about it and I'm like okay
it's just weird you open the Starbucks
and I got so I drove it here it they
gave me a Ferrari they gave you a
Ferrari have money you know probably
making that much money there you got
rich clamp do you have like a lot of
like probably a lot of just like white
girls going in there cuz they all love
Starbucks do they yeah they're making so
much money that they're giving them a
[ __ ] Ferrari on the side and tell
them to keep quiet
yeah so I haven't said anything up until
now are the girls though do the girls
are they or do they look like they've
been indoctrinated as their
there any knitting and is there bacon
going on do they look like do their
heads down yeah you know a show handed
yeah that's exactly what it's like well
dude wearing bonnets and [ __ ]
those are Klan girls who are who are
have low self-esteem and they don't talk
back and probably all pretty young say
anything are they all present three
there's been three pregnant okay then
can I say this Chris have you made any
of the girls pregnant Chris say no it's
Chris yeah listen I'm asking you
honestly but please say no no you're
[ __ ] well I hear well did you make
any of these protein men did you have
sex have sex with the racist makes
racist babies do you've known for way
longer than a day he's bought that
profits he made off his what a [ __ ]
thing this guy's doing he's got a
[ __ ] racist star by soda supposing
impregnating young quiet girls and
bonnets I don't know man you're a friend
and [ __ ] but like like you gotta [ __ ]
you got a ver against condoms of course
they are you gotta make this it feels
better without so they're like we're
making up our own rules
I've gotta make this right yeah dude you
got yeah I will
your characters I promise you that we're
just we I'm gonna make it right today
what are you gonna do what do you do
when you get swear to God
what I'm gonna march right down there
yeah and I'm gonna go home and I'm gonna
[ __ ] I know I'm gonna I'm gonna after
I get a coffee like a [ __ ] [ __ ] sick
I'm gonna say he's gonna get a coffee
you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna open up
a rival [ __ ] coffee house for blacks
know about that
for all a black well now it's actually
not a bad idea
agent it has to be colorblind that
that's the whole point of this guy he's
right I gotta have everybody in there
and then and you have to you're not
gonna drive them out of business you
have to just I'll Drive them out a bill
you have to maybe he just drives them
out of business first with the black
coffee bean then the black [ __ ] now it's
seiken or everybody no you have to just
say this is it illegal and you have to
just shut it he's trying to figure out a
way to [ __ ] deal with no Brian you
can't just go oh sorry
oops fourteen months he has to
proactively and start a black listen to
me listen to me I know how to solve this
problem like I would is I'll get some
mythography when they go in there
they're fighters yeah and we'll go in
there I'm gonna come with him and we're
gonna have pieces of hickory okay and
we're gonna wear this random pieces of
here we're gonna wear him in our pants
and then we're gonna come in and and you
have one of those you know how we gonna
get door they know you're threatening
how they gotta come in it's white so hey
why it's worth yeah hey guys what can I
get you and then I'm gonna have a
[ __ ] you got one of those doors you
have one of the stores there's big
industrial doors cuz it's a Starbucks
yes I management of the computer one of
those big padlocks that you see on ships
with the chains yeah and I'm gonna shine
industrial like padlocks that you'd use
to keep to keep gold in a large chest
yeah and I'm gonna go I'm gonna pull it
I'm gonna pull chain I'm gonna lock the
door and I'm gonna go there now you just
can't leave that's from Bronx Tale go on
now you can't that's the most famous
line moving can't leave shut the fuss
all right sorry that's funny you'll be
in the corner crying like the [ __ ]
Carol bring me with your the race race
apologist racist apologies Robert my
friends gonna plan our hickory and and
have a good old time on some racist
noggins
yeah and that's how we're gonna close
your [ __ ] Starbucks down and there it
was
I never saw Sonny so mad yup he beat up
all those guys all at Starbucks and they
all would regretted the day date crossed
him when he locked the door
said that and close and close upon my
face as I'm done as I'm done making
mincemeat literally of all they're all
that everybody in that Starbucks with my
chicory and I just come up in there's
blood that just it just drips mmm yes
oak the whole time just this and that
music for my funeral is playing and then
I kill myself
what yeah Wow weird weird I know
wait with my own head well yeah with my
guys hey so that was the longest bit
we've ever done love it yeah 25 minutes
it's a bit racist
Starbucks our a source in their races
Starbucks in my head it was really good
back to the to the song glad you guys
drove down here for the hey I'm sorry
you know I just wanted to come by and
say hey Chris but we you have anything
else you want to say well oh [ __ ] I'll
be and where we go in Portland yeah
we'll be importantly I gotta Portland
Oregon and then I got I got Tampa yeah
and then I got and then I got it's good
tea fat K for tickets.com have come to
where the [ __ ] I am
it's gonna open for me maybe will will
Tim I'm heading up north to shoot the
second season of Loudermilk so watch the
first season right now nobody does but
here's and you're on school days I'm on
school school times a school know it's
school holy it's clearly the index it's
called school no yeah I start shooting
the end of August cool very busy
especially you guys know it's sold out
Talia hall but the 19 still some tickets
left
shop what shooting two three episodes of
that school show I'm shooting 13 don't
be this right that's what you get rid of
the pink car by yourself hole saw
Oklahoma Midwest City Oklahoma Dallas
Portland Maine all places
Mashantucket Houston Texas Montreal
Wichita
you know what I mean like I'm going to
score crystal Yadav okay are you
performing anywhere live soon well yeah
like where can I see you just go to
Chris D'Elia calm okay hey calm down man
I'm a fan
all right calm down [ __ ] I'm a
fan alright
not a fan don't be yelling at me cuz I
just want to come see your car you guys
take it easy where are you gonna be soon
I just mentioned where I was okay when's
the next time you're doing comedy I just
said Oklahoma dude
when Thursday okay - why is he do it I'm
a fan man let's take it easy man
oh [ __ ] guys let me ask you this by the
way Syracuse is July 13th and 14th Oh
Gotham and Annika show Gotham July 12th
Thursday in New York City July 12th
it's got some kind of your friend of
mine in New York City don't go no no
like Chris I just ramped up the funny
and that's Bryan Callen so that's what
it is ramp it the [ __ ] up about 17
notches Gotham comedy club
July 12th 13th and 14th Syracuse funny
bone is this the lawn
no what is I'm gonna be cracking wise
with some friends okay get out if you're
around if you're one of my close friends
and we have we share laughs together I
hope you enjoy Jesus Christ
outside of stuff tell my jokes you know
an experience with experience with a bro
with Bryan Callen just do impressions
you know that I would crush a bucket you
[ __ ] [ __ ] I know you said that
about will nice shoes Bryan
uh [ __ ] come on these are [ __ ] my
Pegasus Nike yeah dude where'd you get
those hey hey you guys my wife just sent
me a reminder that she and my kids are
gonna be at the Getty Villa this this
afternoon and the whole thing was they
perform they're gonna go
I guess the Getty Museum to see some
museum exhibit I can't go why not
is it because you're busy or is it
because your brain doesn't allow you to
want to that's my brain have you ever
been to a [ __ ] museum and enjoyed it
ever I mean do I have my phone with me I
like museums to be honest you know that
yeah I really do like you yeah
what it's weird you know what else you
know else I like I love musicals
do you do you serious [ __ ] love them
I would never think I know I'm a
surprise
what did you imagine shocking what music
what music holes have you loved uh
wicked the producers is [ __ ]
hilarious
Wow dude I've gone by myself to see
musicals really I never would've gave
New York you'll go see you might have I
have a Jekyll and Hyde it's all by
myself oh my god amazing
yeah I've seen so many I mean I love
them and what about you I just saw the
play that goes wrong and I love going
the order I rarely know I also while I
was there I saw in and of itself which
is a very interesting illusionist thing
playing till August everybody listen
fighter to the kid have access to New
York I highly recommend it in and of
itself yeah you don't have listeners in
New York with all right you only I know
like this southern listeners that
eyeball you listen a park I yes no
that's not good news
don't do that eyeball you listen to that
tape for your I take a that those are
the guys that see your impression of my
average yeah you listen to that [ __ ]
with the broken side you [ __ ] listen
to TV i caked a he's got a Starbucks in
its own house which I would like to
visit we gotta sell that we need to go
yeah can get any of those Starbucks
drinks that you could have over here at
the mall only the difference is there's
no blames and also they still want to
treat women but ya know what there's no
blanks and the women what which never
speak to the man who make all the rules
[Applause]
so I trade white women love it sack I've
never seen his face he has that you know
to me it could be Bill Cosby what a
[ __ ] awesome ripple at the end of
that bit it's Bill Cosby [ __ ] right
just [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm you know what I am what dum ba na
heat argue it off are you please old not
but I'm [ __ ] he's old but hey you know
what
we're doesn't [ __ ] so but dude I
[ __ ] people I swear to God my name is
that's not really good is it I think
that's my name because they're calling
me how many pairs of shoes do you own
you [ __ ] 150 maybe that's so bad a lot
why do you wear those why those I like
the air max just like golda bad sneakers
out with those big soles
hey dude what you're gonna watch your
[ __ ] mouth
look guys they are why not what's the
large podcast you've ever done for real
okay dude you okay
okay I'm sorry right I flew off the
handle step to me I'll [ __ ] yeah but
I've seen you guys get violent I know
but I flew up the handle I'm sorry
yeah but I'm me just don't go through a
lot I'll [ __ ] racist Starbucks in my
house don't get physical each you've
been able to fun I have a Ferrari but
and you think I what the [ __ ] you know
what just don't don't ever come at me
like that cuz I will meet you halfway
and more guys guys please but you know
it's not get anything so now he's never
had his ass kicked yeah we're [ __ ]
you're going on down I'm undefeated you
know what that means I'm undefeated I
still never had my ass kicked why cuz
I'm undefeated ever fought a guys that's
[ __ ] pepper your face don't fight
alright please don't fight
pepper your face when I was a kid I
[ __ ] was at this Mexican restaurant
and my friend Morgan boys Aki was there
oh yeah I know Morgan and you don't know
Morgan but anyway he's Japanese okay
well don't act like you're cool because
you know the last-named ozaki is
Japanese okay but I'm gonna tell you
this thing that I put salt in my hand
and I said hey Morgan you want to feel
my ninja dust and you said what the [ __ ]
is that and I said you want to feel my
ninja dusties or dog is it I said well
I'm not gonna tell you I have to show
you and he said okay and I threw it in
his eye and it were you doing Oh what
were you doing in that's how he talks
yeah he's really super that's very
stereotypical I wasn't a [ __ ] what were
you doing you doing what you do British
what [ __ ] are you doing my oh that's
actually British he was a British
Japanese guy I thought you were top
geezer you [ __ ] threw salt in the
eyes mate no no no
that's how I heard to Jesus oh he didn't
we doing that's how that's that's
dangerously close to sounding very
stereotypically like condescendingly no
it's not it's not it wasn't like that is
what were you doing with that it wasn't
a Japanese accent what would be a
Japanese guy if a Japanese guys come
here and I'll even speak English for a
little while
and I took salt in his eyes and be
respectful yeah so if I know Solarize
ready that will you take a sword out yes
Banco have swords Japanese we're talking
that's so Condon yeah no no no you know
that flap that they have that they don't
kill you honorably I mean that's okay
what would he say
I mean I don't I don't know Japanese
okay they spoke English this is the end
you would say this is the end or
something very poetic how how Harry
Caray how would he say this is makes you
do it you would say the end is the end
and then you and then you would go right
through you like like a like a like a
like a sword honestly you know what I
was bored so stab me you won all right
but you know what it would it would go
through like a [ __ ] like a knife
through up water
really it would just slice you up yeah
and then he'd he'd he'd look at you you
know he'd make sure to [ __ ] huh you
know and you'd you'd be like you know
and blood would be and it would hit his
face a little bit and you'd look and
he'd be looking who make her oh and it
you know make sure you're looking at him
and when you look at him you'd look at
him and he'd have you'd have tears in
his eyes because you both knew he had to
do that and then you both understood the
honor okay yeah and then you die and
then you
that yeah and when you fall he pull dick
mouth doesn't even look pretty he
honestly gets on top of you know and his
[ __ ] bad ass is or the thing you can
see and he just [ __ ] like [ __ ] your
mouth a little bit like and not if he
doesn't even do it like nice like that
bit I know what he does he goes I guess
just barely into it not into it yeah it
is late
yeah who's this flap so this [ __ ]
dick can get it I know waste action it's
all [ __ ] it is sore legs rough fiction
it's you know I do what dead died the
last insult I get the last word in I go
yeah yeah has anyone ever done this yeah
I do it I like that hey man you guys
have been so disrespectful on my to
everyone really yeah you're a [ __ ] I'm
not a good podcast what are you a [ __ ]
nice hey will
that water jug is too big course it is
no it's not it's so annoying well at
least you don't hold with one hand and
do that about this disrespecting
somebody if somebody starts shooting at
you can hide behind it no yeah yeah you
know what dude just how about this get
one half the size and when you're done
with it
get another one no I need this one it's
got two compartments and the other
compartment holds an extra pair of
shorts [ __ ] Super Deluxe Oh kid and
the sweet two tootin tartar man now
that's not true this has been a [ __ ]
this is big [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
what know what I mean yeah and it's
always like yeah as if that's the
pinnacle of [ __ ] you got a snake in a
white guy's yeah you got like four or
five of them and Bobby Lee fighting for
that [ __ ] thing that's right
who gives all by the wayside of that day
but it give a shine the way just give it
to him then give it to me then give it
to my client away Bobby let me tell you
something right now I didn't promote
that [ __ ] at all
I lost by one percent if I promoted it
good also let me tell you this much if I
if I ever win that I'm making you some
[ __ ] earrings [ __ ] you don't this put
some lorna mints on your [ __ ] lobes
you no disrespect that that's an amazing
award you don't disrespect the begin of
a words what what happened with the
award that I gave you best woman from
the last time I was here I never got it
asked what did I tell you about that if
I don't see it here next time
something's going up your ass
well the [ __ ] award at the [ __ ]
Airport they didn't have as an Oscar I
saw that okay it said best woman and he
was offended by that yeah because he's a
piece of [ __ ] there and so there it is
okay
there it is well then we're fine yeah so
[ __ ] both you guys this is our business
been the fighter and the kid core
strength and what are you doing this
delivering it to do it do it well nice
that's how it should be
hold on it'll figure now nothing well
get it done there you go there you go
perfect
yeah over to him oh that [ __ ] wooden
well the machine the Dinks
we once we won thanks guys thank you
guys I appreciate fresh fish appreciate
you're gonna appreciate you guys I feel
like a long episode of 10-minute podcast
no nose and you guys were out we're out